and I now would like to call upon dr.
Becca scenario who is the vice president
of see far to have the last words please
thank you that well I think the last
word has really been given by the
panelists the whole purpose of the
workshop all purpose of the research
that these people are doing the research
that the people who assembled for the
autism workshop last couple of days has
been to reduce the burden of disease a
disease which has affects many families
and not just in the city or problems but
across the world the and whether that
that disease burden is reduced by a cure
or whether it produced by being able to
find the appropriate interventions that
will enable those people to have high
quality of life to be as fully
functioning individuals that's a real
goal I'd like to thank Steve Marla at
dalkia Leah for showing us how far we've
actually been able to make progress the
toward that particular goal I suspect
you share with me the the challenge that
we are still faceless with really trying
to understand autism they were that what
it's caused by and how we can actually
best deal with it at the same time I'm
also extraordinarily impressed by the
quality of the people and the commitment
Leah of the individual to actually find
those solutions that will in fact here
our children so it's up to me to thank a
few people first I like to thank Steve
for the presentation that was
outstanding thank you
I didn't like to thank merlin vaca the
for not just being here is panelists and
for helping main the bring a somewhat
different perspective on the discussion
but also to organize the workshop that
we've been having this last couple of
days and we'll finish up tomorrow thank
you very much I'd like to thank a number
the organization that have actually made
not just this event this evening
possible but also the workshop of course
OB I done the organization at early in
its life the but i think that the
success of events like this and other
activities that the ontario brain
institute supports the extraordinarily
important and thank you and your staff
or the making all this work i'd like to
thank the Autism Speaks jail fiber for
supporting this event the and the being
of support for the researchers Leah that
are in fact pursuing the solutions they
trying to relieve the burden of autism
they I'd like to also thank a number of
staff who have made this sort of event
possible as many of you know these
things just don't happen they fear the
huge amount of coordination I can tell
you that some of my staff were we're
having of the very interesting months
just coordinating getting people from
several different continents here we all
on the same couple of days and making
sure that everything worked there are a
few people that I think personally that
that should be recognized Sharon Haney
the the the Jordan and flick Michelle
matern curtain island Laura Matthews
these are the people who actually were
at the front and center making this
evening happen and also helped make the
workshop happen the last couple of days
the I know like they'll finally thank
all of you for attending this evening
the my pleasure now to invite you
you to join us in refreshments there are
cookies done don't worry thank the the
in the foyer and that will be the
opportunity to converge on the speaker
than to ask those questions that you
haven't read answers to the seasoning
you thank you again for coming out and
participating with us this evening and
have a good evening